so uh
playing with the fair hub um
it's not that i'm gonna come around here
and get this kind of thing
okay
um but we just start from there
usually you're like uh we're wrestling
okay okay and then uh
as i go
i'm on the mat
let's say he doesn't fall down so i'm
here
and i'm in the bare leg
in the body here
um
he's turned the other way
and you're trying to ambush right
from the back
um
so an ambush might be
the result of a
predation model well i think i could
take her
you got into your ambush all right
so uh
you gotta play with
either one
if your dude dudes sitting there not
trying to protect themselves
give them something okay
and then
don't surrender because
i'll just choke you out
give me a reason
to get half
you did it again
[Music]
okay
let's do that again
you're you're getting it
go
that's not the uk
okay
go let's uh start working it uh
conception okay
so we'll take away the entry i showed
you how you can get into it okay
um
the guy is coming around right he's
coming around to do the barrel all right
um
so
first concept is go
is don't stand straight up
and let your weight go to your heels
you have to get this thing on mid-foot
mid-foot vector okay
some of you are
going
and you're on your heels and oh no
you're toast okay
so as he goes my weight shifts home to
mid-foot vector this is too far
mid-foot vector like you're doing the
back squat okay that's where your power
is
okay don't
back
just like your back squat
don't lower your butt because he's going
to sit you down like you saw me sit sean
down okay it's mid-foot back
so that's our drill guy comes around
big foot vector
we'll do the ambush one two
you'll feel it mid foot vector you can
also deepen your sound so he goes
mid-foot vector deeper
ambush
people my stance midfielder okay let's
just get the weight distribution yeah
hey uh the midfield vector that goes
around uh it's not a bracing angle okay
it's dynamic so as he tries to move me i
keep that mid foot vector not fighting
with him as he he go ahead so you see
he's trying to move me that way i move
that way he's trying to go forward i
move forward because you go backwards i
move backwards keeping that midfoot okay
don't don't sing and brace and settle
it's got to be dynamic with perspective
and that's your drill now
hey uh
next concept is don't get small
don't get small
so you have your uh inward spiral that
you work with and you're going to use
the torso aspect of the inward spiral so
he's coming around
okay
um
he goes again
move strong
throw him here okay
let's say he got uh
one arm so you doing the arm drag
well it'll go underneath it it would be
the technique sean
he does the arm drag hold underneath it
arm drag underneath it
arm drag underneath it okay so you're
going to have
one arm automatically out if you made it
go out
so you have the other arm boom trying to
not be small
here we go
and this is always better
than
this okay here feel the ambush one
you'll feel it
boom
big
okay
let's try it don't be small okay go
okay the next concept
he's going on big midfoot weight is
kazushi so uh
take his balance
okay
he's going
bigger
don't worry if he falls or not you just
can't be standing still okay
again your kazushi angles will just do
it from here slowly
is probably going to if he's coming in
aggressively it's going to be the front
inward on the left
front inward on the right
okay got it i wouldn't be trying uh the
back ones
okay
of course if he's pulling you backward
right then
run inwards in the rear
inward to the other rear okay try it
again
okay so uh
what i'm doing is uh subverting it it's
always easier to disperse something
before it comes to fruition
uh than to try to get rid of it once it
has happened okay
uh but what tends to happen as she's
going is they'll go for other things
because they realize she's never gonna
close her arms do you see that so you
you'll see things like this do you see
or a lot of times it'll stop you'll feel
where's my arm
where do you want to go
here i'll help you
anything
okay so as you're doing this they go
right up
and you're in the headlock
okay um
so coming around subvert and you'll feel
for those things right you're trying to
kasushi and she's doing one of these
things so she's going down for the arm
do you see and she's forgetting this arm
and then
you can
find your movement okay
uh
because she's changing it so she goes up
top
and here out
okay
to do this
you have to stop wrestling with them
she goes you don't want to start
wrestling and this kind of stuff okay
you want to keep your art so i feel her
and you let that go look here's the
opening
so i was big
right but if she's trying to get the arm
i'll go small
i'm not
see that so don't contest the things
again if you're static
it's harder to do those things so make
sure you're first doing the kazushi
she'll go for whatever
and then you go and respond to that
without contesting it okay
try it go do a kind of side note insert
um
we'll just look at the arms are free
come in please verify
okay
so uh this isn't very good because you
have a lot of strikes but you have a lot
of disarm so you can look at his grip
and you're out you see now
he lost everything so we'll look at this
script here that he has i'm going to
come on top right
and just push
down with my two hands so same grip
defense two on one keep yourself big
he'll do whatever and
you
here's your spiraling geometry okay
so we'll just start static
look at his grip this one's going that
way do you see that so don't attack the
bottom arm this is the arm that's
reinforcing so attack the reinforcing
arm out it goes keep your contact again
whatever he's doing look at it
push down okay let's try that come on
this one
so
again diagnose the grip so don't take
the top hand this time you're going to
take the bottom hand okay pull them this
way
here
take the bottom hand if i had to i would
put my thumbs in there um but i'm not
using my thumbs i'm just getting my
thumbs in there they start to use my
heel palms okay again the weight
distribution is going mid foot low base
this kind of uh rear posterior chain
torso angle and then you're working
the bottom grip so he's gripping very
tight right and you're just working on
two arms against finger strength okay
all right try it
oh people do weird things so you don't
ever know
even though those are the two most
common grips you might have captain kirk
and you raise your fingers
you see
and here you're gonna find those other
two they kind of work and stuff but it
also opens itself up
to other
pink appliance stuff so
which you can do in the other one so
let's say he has the other grips and
he's really freaking strong and i can't
push it maybe i could just get it uh
loosen up with this knuckle tank you see
so i just i just get it loosen up and
then
i can maybe get it so uh we're just
gonna show that
we'll just use this one
okay
so you're going to take the the phoenix
fist here this middle knuckle fist and
you're just going to put it in the back
of the hand if you need more energy you
just
use the other hand and you're gonna rub
it like a
like a cpr
chest rub okay
and now you're out okay
um we'll do that one
and then
uh another one is the finger so you're
going to get underneath and use your
hands to get those fingers out you see
and then you have the
pain
so you can work either of those okay all
right so let's play it
okay uh this last concept you have is
one that you use all the time in your
tachiwasa and in your network
is uh don't be
where the attack requires you to be so
you know if you don't want to uh
to be
let's say you're you're in someone's
closed guard and you don't want to get
yourself stuck
in the
triangle armbar omoplata dilemma don't
lean
forward into that 45 degree angle does
you got no business being there and the
best thing to do then is don't pass
close cards
uh seated because you're likely going to
get there so you got no business being
there if you same thing the best way to
get out of side control is never assume
side controlled
position don't you got no business being
there okay so as the guy comes around
we're still working with this geometry
is working because he's behind me and
i'm over here you see that so uh a
simple just turn just get this thing not
where he wants it to be you see that
you see and now this thing already
changed
so um you it's not like the other one
where i'm trying to throw him i'm just
trying to change this geometry just
enough you see and now he's not where he
wanted to be okay
and now you have all kinds of other
attacks
so you've got the ankle here
which is very much
on there
and you have the groin with the heel
hook
over here you see that
without forfeiting
your balance that's not a good shot
because i can't bleed with the heel from
there you see from this angle and then
this really compromises my balance so
inside his movement just that was enough
that's enough and you're going to get
that heel to leave there and
you'll get your heel hook into the groin
that thing will loosen right because
and you're going
and now you're
out of the technique too so
um within what he's doing
get a movement
if he has
a higher base or a shallower base
you see because maybe he's trying to
pick me up
right
then you can't even change that
relationship entirely
okay so
we'll do the y base
change this find the spine relationship
we'll do the narrow base and just
get out of that entirely get out of in
front of him as well okay